wednesday the new york times ran an
anonymous op-ed by a white house
official
trapping trashing donald trump forget
this
being donald trump yes apparently he's a
tough old boss
i'd say stop the presses but brian
stelter might accuse me of actually
demanding the paper be closed
the guy takes everything literally you
tell him a knock knock joke and he looks
for the door
so a lot of people want to know who
captain anonymous is
so far the people denying it's them are
mike pence mike pompeo
mike brady dan coats
james mattis flipper
rick perry ben carson
herbie the love bug gina haspel
kellyanne conway and crackle from snap
crackle and pop
but the big scoop this week some
employees
just don't like their boss yep this is
pulitzer stuff
a boss known for being inquisitive and
blunt is exposed as
inquisitive and blunt i know it's
terrible
he's rude he doesn't say hi in the
hallways
he once forgot my birthday yep no giant
chocolate chip cookie cake for me
but what really kills me it's so obvious
this dreck was written by a pissed off
flunky
the assistant to the assistant regional
manager
if you worked in an office you know what
i'm talking about he's the guy who won't
do the job he's asked to do
and his boss is pissed and you and he
should be
pissed you dumbass how odd is it that
woodward's book
and this piece appeared at the same time
perhaps they're all from the same source
[Music]
and that source is telling us that yes
donald trump is a big meanie
a jerk but also a highly competent one
yep buried in this emotional screed is
one searing admission
the country's safer and more prosperous
under trump
yep two meaningless variables safety and
prosperity
it's a shame trump's done nothing about
the real problems we face
like condiment water you know when you
turn over the ketchup and mustard
container and it looks like the bottle
is peeing on your sandwich
or how to get melted cheese off a plate
when you forgot to rinse it the night
before
it's like cement you're there for day i
throw the plate out
or when you run out of toilet paper and
you end up having to use this
[Applause]
or this
ignore this
yes
nope just prosperity and safety
no well the only two variables that
matter are now reduced to
a sentence and yet that's one sentence
cancels out everything else
in this sucky piece fact if it takes a
jerk to make a country great
then hell let's bring on the jerks hi
i'm kathy von vandertrap and i'm running
to be your senator
so there's about four years where i
don't remember a thing
like around 02 to 06 give or take a few
years
wow i was drunk one time i got arrested
for trying to board a riverboat
naked and that was at disneyland i was
also in season three of intervention
i'm the one addicted to window cleaner
and i'm still paying off my sister for
crashing her car and into an atm
in order to get money to buy an xbox so
vote kathy von vandertrap
for u.s senate paid for by the jerk
party
so this week's scoops are more of the
same drivel
absent of russian collusion and faced
with a great country becoming greater
it's now
hallway whispers from underlings about a
jerky boss
it's cry babies versus the jerk and
these crybabies pretend
there were no jerks before trump sorry
the people pushing a moral crisis today
in previous campaigns
were flinging in mud like chimps on
metamucil
trump talks trash but does so out in the
open
he's a jerk i'm a jerk we need a new
party for jerks
hey it's me tim mctimmons i want to be
your next governor
in the early 80s i made a number of
films under an assumed name
i would call them art pictures but hey
let's be honest
they were porn and i'm not gonna lie
like serious porn this stuff will curl
your toes folks
anyway i cleaned up my act and now i'm
totally legit
except for the robbery charges which i
pled no contest for
right now i just want to best serve you
once i'm done serving time for last
week's drunken disorderly
so vote tim mctimmons for governor paid
for by the jerk party
it's hard to be a jerk it's hard to be a
jerk
and that's the problem for trump for him
bedside manner is for losers
because only failures need it a bad
doctor needs a great personality because
he keeps losing patience
but trump's all about good news so let's
assess
first trump was crazy then he was hitler
then he was racist
now he's just a big meanie yep a jerk
so what accept it embrace it hell let's
join the party
hi i'm rodney razorshortz as you know
i'm running for congress
and as election day nears things are
gonna get pretty hot
so i guess i should get this off my
chest i am on my third marriage
the first two didn't go so well probably
because of the
rampant philandering my kids still hate
me after i spent christmas with that
flight attendant
i lived with my parents mainly because i
lost my life savings betting on illegal
bare knuckle boxing matches in my
cousin's basement
all right let's just say i have a few
skeletons in my closet
and by that i mean human bodies devoid
of flesh
but i keep as my personal trophies
anyway
i figured this is all going to come out
in the end anyway so i might as well
beat the press to it
so you vote for razor shorts for
congress
tell them rodney sent you paid for it by
the jerk party
period let's welcome
tonight's guests she's my co-host on the
five
and she once dated a guy named troy
that's not true
that's not true my mom told me when i
was 13 don't go on the three-wheelers
with those boys with troy
and now chiropractor was one of them
troy
one of these days we'll find out troy's
last name and we won't be reunited i
hope he's hideous
he's not hideous believe me that
call us troy it's dana perrino
if giggles were drugs he'd be your
favorite dealer
his new album is called three's comedy
writer and comedian joe devito
she's got a lot of spunk and likes to
get crunk national review reporter cat
tim
his sneezes cause breezes former wwe
superstar my massive sidekick
tyrus
all right let's get started dana uh what
do you make of this whole article you
have a theory don't you have a theory
about this a couple of theories
a couple of theories yeah so usually
if you are serving the president of the
united states you do it because you are
an
honorable person with dignity and
integrity and class
this joker is not that
the new york times decided to publish
this okay fine whatever free country
first amendment
a senior administration official could
be somebody as lowly as i used to be
at the white house when i was a deputy
press secretary that is a legit senior
administration official
also it's not the white house right it's
a senior administration official that
means across the entire government
someone working for the epa regional
office right in colorado
that could actually be this person the
other thing about it is that
they say that they're being so effective
right they're being so effective
protecting the country
if that's the case keep your mouth shut
very good
yeah all right
what gets me mad is i've been in a lot
of companies and i know people like this
that are like
they are uh they don't like the boss and
so they they like they're passive
aggressive
well why aren't you president then like
you didn't run and you didn't win so
shut the f
up yeah nobody voted for this person and
yeah
i think it's strange that you can't act
like you're a member of the resistance
when you're still in the same
healthcare plan as the evil empire
you're fighting against
yeah if it's really that bad become a
former
senior administration official say your
name and go out there and make some real
change
and i think it's interesting that
they're saying like oh we're keeping
trump away from doing any damage though
even things are going well
well let's think this through if things
are going well and people don't know
this is happening and trump doesn't even
know what's going to happen
he's doing it and he's going to get
elected for another four years yes
because you made him look good you're
dope
it doesn't make any sense yeah it
doesn't cat do you think there's a
theory that actually there is no mole
and that this was written by the new
york times could that be the answer here
i don't know i think it was written by a
mole but like dana i think that it's
possible this is a very low level person
doesn't have to be a mike pence it
doesn't have to be a
kelly i think though that we're
eventually going to find out who this
person is
because like i've said before there's an
entire genre of books that we're going
to have
the disgruntled former employee of the
trump administration genre
yeah and i think that this person is
probably just practicing
right this could be a good book proposal
of sorts exactly so
i think eventually he'll want to come
out and try to be a hero of the left
which he will be
even though he was maybe you know worked
somewhere in the
low-level agriculture department and i
love that i get called
you mean he's a farmer no i just it was
the first apartment that came to my head
for some reason why are you knocking
farmers they're great americans
how did how is that a knock to farmers i
don't know i just want to get angry
letters directed at her
thank you i'm tired of them coming to me
all right tyrus any thoughts on the jerk
party
i feel like i could be the first
candidate for the jerk party
yeah you're the only candidate for the
jerkbait
listen everybody um i did it
and i have a reason why i want to be
press secretary for the day
and they wouldn't let me so
[Music]
i read a couple pages of all the bad
books
and i wrote a letter and i sent it to
new york times they didn't even call me
they just
printed it so
by the way i'm gonna accept that
out on face value so it's up to the
times to dispute this
that tyrus actually i do this he
wouldn't let me be press secretary for
the day so i told how horrible of me to
work for him
i i do believe it's an opinion piece by
a pissed off underling
omarosa did it if i didn't do it
i know but i did it i will say that it
is possible this person will
unveil himself before this show airs and
then well
the other thing is it just did i don't
understand
why this is so difficult i did it okay
that's true
i haven't saved all my notes on my
iphone i'll give it to you after the
show
what did you say last week well i'm just
going to say that um that this is a
person who is being given the
advantage of being called a senior
administration official that is worth
something
because while you have the benefit and
the power there it
you can be you can bet that this person
is out scouting
for their next private sector job of
which they're probably going to have a
higher salary a higher title
more power and so it's a real jerk move
yeah it is a journey yeah because it
didn't work
i didn't get the thing you guys know
contributing editor at vanity fair will
be the new title
six figures maybe low seven for real yes
okay then i did